der riesen brocken florence rast auf die
erde zu am ersten september 2017 wird er
der erde wohl so nahe kommen wie kein so
großer asteroiden zuvor gefährlich
macht ihn zum einen seine kreuzung zur
erdbeeren und zum anderen seine größe
er gehört zu den größten erdnahen
asteroiden überhaupt astronomie teams
weltweit sind vorgewarnt und schon im
nächsten monat soll ein weiterer street
der erde gefährlich nahe kommen
inzwischen kennt man die entfernung
besser in der sich der erde nähern wird
wie groß die gefahr diesmal wirklich
ist jetzt den klicks um science-fiction
herzlich willkommen
schon seit 36 jahren nahmen
forschungsteams weltweit den wirklich
riesigen hast du diesen florence im
blick 1981 hatte ihn ein us astronom
entdeckte am freitag den ersten
september ist es dann soweit er wird so
nah dran an der erde erwartet wie kein
so großer asteroid zuvor astronomie
teams weltweit sind deshalb vorgewarnt
und erwarten den tag mit großer
spannung währungskurse von 4,35
kilometern das ist wirklich immens und
seine kreuzung zu erdbeeren machen ihn
so gefährlich seitdem vor etwa einem
jahrhundert der erste ärger hast du
überhaupt entdeckt wurde ist florence
tatsächlich der größte us solid der
so nah an uns vorbei fliegt mit einem
abstand von 7.000 millionen kilometern
so 7 milliarden kilometer nämlich und
in astronomischen maßen see ist das
tatsächlich wenig allerdings nasa teams
zufolge ist dies immer noch weit genug
entfernt um eine gefahr für die erde
auszuschließen und trotzdem haben sie
sich den tag rot im kalender markiert
die nasa plant rava messung zum beispiel
von kalifornien und puerto rico aus und
auch viele teleskope werden den
vorbeiflug von florence beobachten und
sicher nicht umsonst denn der asteroid
wird wohl heller am himmel strahlen als
beispielsweise 2014 nur 25 der mit einer
distanz von 1,8 millionen kilometern an
der erde vorbei gerauscht ist klar denn
er war auch nur 650 meter groß wenn das
wetter mitspielt könnte sogar möglich
sein florence mit einem guten fernglas
zu entdecken und im oktober geht es
tatsächlich weiter mit einem asteroiden
in unserer nähe am 12 oktober wird wohl
ein weiterer asteroid die erde nur knapp
verfehlen
und das ist wirklich knapp diesmal das
sind die neuen zahlen wohl nur mit einem
abstand von 44.000 kilometern ganz
schön nahe wenn man bedenkt dass die
geostationären satelliten in einer
entfernung von 36 kilometern von uns
entfernten konkret handelt es sich um
den asteroiden 2012 tc 4
nach berechnungen der forschungsteams
von esa und nasa besteht auch hier keine
anschlagsgefahr dieser suite ist in etwa
15 bis 20 meter lang und wurde 2012
entdeckt damals konnte er aufgrund
seines vorlaufes allerdings nur wenige
tage proben
werden seine größe endet übrigens dem
asteroiden der im februar 2013 über
russland explodiert ist allerdings erst
noch mal zehn mal größer also vom
volumen her die explosion des
chelyabinsk asteroiden hatte damals
lediglich eine druckwelle ausgelöst sie
beschädigte mehrere tausend gebäude
und verletzte rund 100 menschen ein
einschlag dagegen hätte die stadt
komplett zerstört verglichen mit der
hiroshima bombe hatte diese ass et die
20 bis 40 fache sprengkraft entsprechend
tnt waren es 600 kilotonnen asteroiden
sind ja ein überbleibsel von der
entstehung unseres sonnensystems die
meisten von ihnen ziehen
glücklicherweise weit entfernt von der
erde ihre runden um die sonne zwischen
den planeten mars und jupiter und doch
die erde ist ständig bedroht von
kollisionen mit erdnahen asteroiden
viele objekte sind klein und verglühen
in der atmosphäre ohne dass wir es
bemerken dass ein himmelskörper in die
atmosphäre eindringt und explodiert
oder ein schräg das kommt allerdings
öfter vor als wir denken
wie oft das in den letzten 13 jahren
passiert ist das wurde ja erst jüngst
bekannt wir haben darüber berichtet 26
asteoriden sind auf der erde in 13
jahren eingeschlagen darauf gekommen
sind findige wissenschaftler und
wissenschaftlerinnen sie hatten die idee
beim weltweiten atomteststopp
überwachungs netzwerk nachzufragen ob
es andere größere explosionen auf der
erde gab und es waren 26 in 13 jahren
lediglich ein einschlag wurde dabei
vorher gesehen alle anderen kamen im
wahrsten sinne des wortes aus heiterem
himmel jedes jahr schlagen also zwei
größere asteroiden hier auf der erde
ein
bisher hatten wir großes glück denn
die gesteinsbrocken schlugen im meer
wüsten oder sonstigen unbewohnten
gebieten ein und verdampften bereits in
der atmosphäre jetzt will die nasa bei
2012 tc 4
die abwehr von erster jeden testen
erster schritt die nachverfolgung des us
zu ihnen 2012 tc 4 kennen wir zwar schon
seit fünf jahren aber in dieser zeit
konnten wir ihn nur sieben tage
beobachten der vorbeiflug soll jetzt
genutzt werden um die asteroiden
erkennung und nachverfolgung zu testen
denn das ist die voraussetzung um in
zukunft asteroiden aufzuspüren und dann
zu zerstören oder ihre flugbahn zu
ändern zum ersten mal kommt die neue
behörde planetary die fans koordination
also planeten verteidigungsreaktion zum
einsatz
diese hatten die usa letztes jahr
eingerichtet um erdnahe asteroiden zu
entdecken und zu verfolgen sie gelten
als auslöser von massensterben auf der
erde alle paar millionen jahre mal
steuert ein großer asteroid auf die
erde zu der das leben tatsächlich
bedroht die nase hat deswegen das ziel
bis 2020 alle erdnahen asteroiden
die zumindest größer als 140 meter
sind zu entdecken denn genau diese sind
die größte gefahr für die erde
experten plädieren deshalb immer wieder
für eine bessere weltweite
zusammenarbeit und den aufbau eines
koordinierten frühwarnsystems wirklich
effektive abwehr strategie n a
die gibt's noch gar nicht die sind noch
nicht ausgetüftelt wir können also
froh sein dass die beiden jetzt
erwarteten hast du jeden wohl wirklich
keine gefahr für das leben auf der erde
darstellen allerdings müssen wir
fürchten dass einer der statistisch
gesehen zwei asteroiden die das ja hier
einschlagen in einer gegend auf trifft
in der millionen menschen leben diese
beiden asteroiden werden es nicht sein
aber vielleicht einer den wir noch nicht
entdeckt haben hier bei pixum sind also
jeden eines unserer top themen wenn ihr
kein video zum thema und auch zu allen
anderen themen verpassen wollt dann
sollten wir hier ein abo aufs auge und
vergesst nicht den auf die glocke hier
also hier geht es weiter mit astro ihn
bedrohen die erde jederzeit mit noch
mehr infos zu den gefahren die von
asteroiden ausgehen spannendes video
klar
also nicht verpassen und draufklicken
viel spaß dabei und ansonsten bis dann
bleibt